I just brought home these absolute gems
from the library they're written by
Charles Hinton this one an episode of
flatland hails from 1907 while the other
simply titled the fourth dimension dates
back to 1904. on the inside page is this
mesmerizing fold out of hinton's cubes
these colored blocks were once sold as
part of an 81-piece set designed to help
you imagine a fourth dimension of space
by arranging the cubes to construct what
might be the cross-sections of a 4D
hypercube visiting our world look here
and you'll see an inscription from
perhaps this book's last reader Campbell
in 1922 tucked inside I found their
bookmark a tram ticket seeing it I feel
a bridge to the Past a shared Wonder for
this topic it's a curiosity that spans
generations and I'm honored to hold this
piece of History until I need to return
it